you
[Music]
hi everybody
thank you my name is Tyler Morgan wall
and today I'm going to be talking to you
about 3d mapping plotting and printing
with ray shader so a little about myself
I have a PhD in physics from Johns
Hopkins University and I work at the
Institute for Defense analyses in
Alexandria Virginia I'm the developer of
four packages ray shader skipper ray
focus and adjusted cram logs but this
slide mostly exists in case you don't
recognize me from my very outdated
Twitter profile picture because we all
look a little different on the internet
I'm gonna answer a few questions in this
talk first and foremost what is ray
shader why did I develop it and how can
you use it to make beautiful maps and
visualizations second I'm going to spend
a few minutes trying to convince you
that 3d plots aren't as bad as some
people make them out to be and can be an
effective tool in your visualization
arsenal and finally I'm going to talk a
bit about some of the non-coding
activities that you can do to develop
your projects and how you can take
advantage of the great our community ray
shader is a package designed to create
maps in art and by create Maps
I mean generating maps directly from
elevation data this is in contrast to
building maps off of pre-existing tiles
there's nothing wrong with using tiles
to build your map but it does limit your
aesthetic options to whatever the
creator of those tiles decided on by
generating our Maps directly from the
source elevation data we can have full
control over their appearance so this is
what happens when you plot elevation
data with base are using the image
function the code is on the left in the
output is on the right this is Hobart
Tasmania but looks more like two amoebas
dueling out dueling it out in pond scum
or as base are calls it terrain colors
here the Hobart object is nothing more
than a base our matrix here is the
reishi ater version of that plot using
spherical shading it's a much more
naturalistic view of the data while you
lose the direct mapping of color to
elevation you gain a much more human
understanding of the landscapes contours
note how details appear that weren't
apparent in the base our plot namely the
fact that there is a river between these
two mountains ray shader is built around
elevation data and building a plot works
similarly to how you build a plot in
ggplot with layers here I've added a
water layer simply by calling the detect
water and add water functions and reishi
ater with the elevation matrix this
overlays a water layer on top of the
sphere shade layer now ray shaders name
comes from the fact that it uses ray
tracing to shade topographic maps so
much like we added our water layer here
we can add a shadow layer simply by
calling the add shadow function with the
Ray shade function this trace is raised
for each point on the elevation matrix
determines at that point is in shadow or
light and shades it appropriately the
add shadow function layers it onto the
existing plot passed in using the pipe
operator we can continue stacking
different types of shadows with
additional calls to add shadow here we
add an ambient occlusion layer which
models atmospheric scattering and makes
valleys darker than ridges we now have
in my opinion a beautiful
2d topographic map but if you think
about it our data is already inherently
3d x y&z elevation so in reishi ater
transitioning from 2d to 3d is as simple
as swapping out the plot map function
with the plot 3d function note how the
only data used to generate all of this
is the base our matrix no special data
structures once you're able to get your
data into that form you can focus solely
on perfecting the aesthetics of your map
speaking of aesthetics changing them in
reishi Eider is incredibly simple
there are seven built-in pallets and you
can create your own using the create
texture function the last one is the
unicorn palette however one thing that
bothered me when I first made that plot
was although it is very cool as a 3d
surface it was representing solid earth
but the plot itself looked flimsy and
infinitesimally thin like you could just
blow it away if you breathe too hard so
I made it so you could set solid equals
true in the plot 3d function and reishi
ater would automatically render a solid
3d object
this changes the aesthetic from pseudo
3d surface to actual 3d model something
you can imagine holding in your hand
putting at your desk and fidgeting
around with you don't have to imagine
though
because I built into reishi Aitor
the ability to export your maps to a 3d
printable format with no external
software required so this is Hobart
Tasmania the same place note that the
top figure is rendered in reishi ater in
the bottom figure is rendered in real
life note how close with the two matches
as it rotates and compare the similarity
to the shadows on the surface of the 3d
model I have the model right here with
me if you want to see me afterwards and
check it out most importantly adding
this feature led me to the moment I knew
hi had made it as an art programmer
because my cat finally showed an
interest in what I was doing
so none of the built-in data sets in are
really showcased all these features so I
included a new data set with radiator of
Monterey Canyon in Monterey Bay
California here you can see where ray
shader really starts to shine combined
representations of the 3d
representations of topographic and
bathymetric data so our planet is going
through an immense period of change and
much of that change is focused around
our coasts one of the main goals I had
with reishi ATAR was to make it dead
simple to make beautiful engaging
visualizations combining land and water
here all the user has to do to model a
changing coastline is to set the depth
of the water in either plot treaty or
the render water function R a shader
handles all of these rendering and
slicing so a good visualization needs
context and the render label function
allows you to drop label seamlessly into
your maps just with the row and column
index in your matrix the render label
you can easily customize with your line
shape font with height color anything
you can do an R GL so annotating your
maps is a very serious use of reishi
ater this is not
but in addition to adding shadow and
water layers you can also hope overlay
arbitrary images and data on your maps
normally you could imagine this being
used for something serious like you know
public health data or pollution
statistics but so far I've mostly used
it to throw animated gifs on my maps
your visualization is your choice one
issue though I had with the raw 3d
visualizations is how CG they looked I
wanted reishi aters output to look like
a real model so one way to do that was
to make it look like it was being imaged
by a real camera so this is the render
depth function where I built a virtual
camera into reishi ater that simulates a
depth of field effect the interface to
do this is dead simple you just pass in
a focal point in focal lens or f-stop
and you just call the render depth
function and then ratio renders this
beautiful post-processing bokeh effect
finally you're not limited to square
maps with reishi Eider anymore simply by
setting the points you want to remove to
n/a you can R's missing value you can
shape your map into anything you want
ray shader intelligently slices and
renders the resulting map and you can 3d
print it so it's an easy gift for all of
your geographically inclined friends so
all of that covers the current state of
ray shooter but there's a lot of cool
features coming soon several which I'm
excited to announce for the first time
here at our studio conference so soon
you're going to be able to explore your
a shader visualizations in virtual
reality augmented reality has compact
HTML embeddable 3d assets and in
external 3d software such as blender and
this is possible because I added to be
added to reishi 8 or the ability to
export to gltf 2.0 which is the next-gen
3d Assaf asset file transfer
transmission format
so this means their data visualizations
are no longer stuck in our you can
include them in your you can make them
put them in the web and include them in
standard 3d graphics workflow workflows
so that sums up the current and future
state of Radiator but I think I know III
think I know what many people came here
to see 3d GG plots which are coming next
that that will be in the next release of
of Radiator but before I release this to
the public I do need to address the
small contingency of people who would
say that I shouldn't even release this
feature because 3d plots only exist to
impede interpretation and are an affront
to good visualization practices so our
3d plots always bad know the idea of 3d
plots being bad stems from the fact that
3d has often been used gratuitously
where the data itself is inherently 2d
or 1d and 3d is just added for visual
fluff when a data has a legitimate 3d
mapping creating a 3d plot is perfectly
fine there's also the idea that since
the display medium is 2d 3d plots are
not appropriate so here's two examples
from the source of all things
cartographic in the US the USGS the
atlas of oblique maps published in 1988
contains beautiful 3d representations of
topographic and bathymetric data unlike
a 2d contour or color map you don't need
to have a degree in cartography or to
read a color bar to know what's going on
the 3d structure of the landscape is
immediately apparent
some might say well that's just
illustration that's not data vis but
that's not the case the cartographers of
the USGS actually created these maps by
using what's called an isometric graph
which mass maps contours to 3d to their
3d projection these maps were based off
of actual data visualized in 3d and even
in 1988 photographers understood
something very important about these
types of visualizations
incredibly engaging and easy to
understand and this type of engaging
tool is important when trying to
communicate complex ideas and analyses
about our changing planet each
visualization is part of a story and
sometimes the idea that the
visualization needs to be so precisely
constructed that the reader could take a
ruler to the plot and reconstruct the
data set manually needs to take a
backseat to the story you're trying to
tell this visualization was not made
with reishi ater
but I thought it was a great example of
a 3d map that tells a story on its own
the change in ground water in Southern
California over time shows how the water
table is breathing with this
visualization be as effective or
engaging without the 3d I don't think so
the 3d brings the data to life in a way
a color map or a use of small multiples
wouldn't this animation is likely what
caused this article to go viral and be
exposed to thousands of people and
science that is communicated to the
general public and Stokes their interest
is infinitely more valuable than science
that just Stokes the interest of those
in academia and 3d tools our 3d
visualizations are a great way to do
just that
so finally I'm going to talk a bit about
how non-coding activities can propel
your projects forward as I found out
with ray shader and also act as a nice
respite for when you've crashed are
twenty times in a row using C++ so
writing about your projects is more than
just marketing it's also a great tool to
get yourself brainstorming when
describing the original 3d modelling
blog post I wrote about this I wrote I
didn't want the map to look like a
carefully cranked old sheet of paper I
wanted a 3d presentation that looks like
a paperweight which immediately got me
thinking why not try 3d printing it what
would it take for me to implement that
what do I need to learn to do this in
this case writing led to an idea which
led to I think a really cool feature
creating animations that show off on
Twitter is fun but they also serve as
double duty as tests of reishi Eider I
found so many bugs by producing these
animes
yeah here you can see one where the text
label when it's underneath the
transparent surface only disappears at
certain angles this is still a bug but
but I found lots of floating-point
issues and all these things that only
happen out of two out of three hundred
and sixty frames and my animations so
it's a really great way to kind of test
your software if you make something you
know visual based and finally I found
out when I've been making ray shooter
I've gotten three important types of
feedback the are stats community is a
great resource you should definitely
take advantage of interacting with the
greater community again is not just
marketing the feedback you get can
dramatically improve your code when you
post your project online you get these
three different important types of
feedback inspiration of course seeing
people do unexpected and just play
playing cool things with your project
when you have hundreds of creative
capable and analytical minds working
with your software they can do things
that you're not even going to think of
this is just a small selection of some
of the cool projects over the last eight
months Rader has existed and some very
cool stories I I think had Lee said that
it was the quickest I think a package
has gone from release to in a major
newspaper I with this Wall Street
Journal story but yet the stuff I've
seen has been incredible
then there's shame so if you ask the
internet how to do something in my case
develop a ray tracer to shade
topographic maps you'll likely get a
kind of passive-aggressive link to the
Wikipedia page for ray tracing with
maybe a link to a Stack Overflow post
but if you make an attempt and tell the
Internet that you've created a ray
tracer to shade topographic maps you'll
get a bunch of beautifully pedantic
people coming out of the woodwork to do
an in-depth code review to tell you
exactly what you did wrong
which if you can stomach it is a great
way to help figure out where you want to
bring your project so you're never too
good to find all of your bugs so you
need the community to find your bugs for
you and sometimes it can be good to get
shamed into programming things that
aren't exactly fun to program like
making your programs more efficient or
use less memory I had to do this after
this great blog post that came out about
entirely how it's low reishi ater was so
finally motivation this is just a
montage of tweets over the last few
months of people expressing how excited
they are in following what's going on in
ray shader seeing people's excitement
and interest in your project as Marie
Kondos puts it sparks joy the art
community in particular is one of the
nicest and most supportive program in
communities out on the internet so if
you have a project you are working on
that you are proud of it's likely that
there will be a bunch of people online
that will love it too
so in summary make maps with ray shader
use 3d write about your projects and
tweet your heart out thank you
[Applause]
oh and if you ask a question I have a
little 3d printed volcano data set that
will I'll give it to you so because
you're speaking in front of hundreds of
people - so as though you need
motivation at mic sir
hey I'm curious if there's a way to
adjust the light source that's used for
the shadow that you can add yeah no that
that's one of the that's one of the
arguments in in ratio listen you can you
can adjust thinking adjust the width to
make it a finite size source but yeah
super cool thanks and you get a volcano
can you kind of explain a little bit why
I would want to see my maps and
augmented reality well why wouldn't you
it's super cool cool why would it well
it's just it's you know it's just I
don't really know why I mean true it's
just one of those cool things that you
can do and it's like why not I think
it's like I actually have if you want to
meet me afterwards I have a little
marker I can show you how it works and
it's operates on your phone and you can
actually hold the marker and hold the 3d
object in your hand and I think it's
more of a science communication thing to
show your data in real life and it just
like normally people might look at and
be like oh data whatever but if you can
actually give them and let it then hold
it I mean even though it's really boring
data they could be like wow this is so
cool
groundwater I was one word I was
wondering if it was possible to see the
different types of biological
environments or different types of
forests that you could put on your so
you can use anything actually for the
actual image files so ratio those
functions just create an image file
which maps onto there so if you actually
imported your images or created a
different texture to represent those
regions you could put that on your 3d
map so one more if you were to overlay a
street map on to yeah so is it that you
just need the yeah you just need an
image file with the same extent the same
range and then you could use the overlay
image function you can specify
transparency or they can
Transparency so you can lay it on top
possible thanks right we have one last
question here and then you can ask Tyler
after I've really did the first question
can you set the like the time of day of
the Sun that's been a long-standing
issue that was one of the original
features I wanted to add was just give a
date time and lat/long to specify the
place of the Sun there's there's some
code out there that does that it's
pretty simple to do but yeah you can you
can do that manually for now but it's
I've kept that issue open for six months
because I've been meaning to do
something for them
[Music]